nel partito si è partito ciao ragazzi
prima di iniziare questo video volevo
dirvi che siamo molto professionali
condiviso quindi cerchiamo le posizioni
giuste volevo dirvi ragazzi che faccio
questa piccola premessa sono e non
dovete lanciarmi devo interrompere
bruscamente tutti i raduni che andrò a
fare durante quest'anno quindi per un
anno non farò incontri perché voglio
concentrarmi moltissimo sul canale in
questo periodo voglio portare molti
contenuti nuovi che vedrete poi alzare
proprio la qualità di bestia del canale
e quindi non farò più eventi o incontri
per circa un anno intero quindi se
volete vedermi incontrarmi dovete
tenervi tutto per un anno ci sarà un
paio di eccezioni ovviamente quindi il
romics game pixar o si erano mix che la
games week
e a dicembre sarò ad una fiera e poi
basta non farò più nulla per un annetto
e poi l'anno dopo invece riprendiamoci
il tempo che è quindi se volete veder mi
volete dividere noi che non sto
registrare solo sopra si capiscono un
sacco di cose
salve persone allora sono qua con mio
padre che era un sacco di tempo che non
facevo video
con papa nico l'ultimo posto insieme
quando il successo un anno fa un anno in
meno quasi un anno è passato un bravo
undici metri va beh era da un annetto
che non facevamo video insieme quindi
era da un po che volevo fare questa cosa
siccome l'ho fatta con tutti i miei
amici oggi giochiamo a v.no e it e rino
si chiamava comunque una roba che ti
mette due opzioni potevi scegliere quale
tu vorresti usare quindi ad esempio la
prima di oggi per farti un esempio per i
resti controllare gli elementi impazziva
per poi c'è una traduzione fanno schifo
per creare google del tempo come volta
controllare gli elementi oppure
controllare il tempo quale le due
preferiresti di fare niente questo
questo gioco che devi scegliere
e poi c'è la percentuale di gente che ha
scelto uno all'altro bari ed eva di una
sega di controllare il tempo
io preferirei lusso si contrae il tempo
di vedere quanta gente ha messo
puntualità 65 per cento metri
adesso niente allora preferiresti essere
la persona più conosciuta in una band la
band è conosciuta da meno di 200 di
persone oppure essere nella tua band
preferita tipo it può però essere quello
meno conosciuto di quella band è capito
quello che unisce il rottame i microfoni
cessi pulis chi come i successi dei poco
e preferire stesi se avendo naturalmente
200 duecento persone che dirà il ragazzo
ingenti in realtà lui ha una band che la
conoscono non 200 persone o meno il fai
che indichi e non sono neanche il più
famoso di questa sera che vi fosse
diretta assolutamente polari tessile
vacanza a new york city io vacanza tokyo
qua avremo una divergenza
ed ora è dura per una pagina di cultura
proprio penso in cultura diversa
veramente se sia assolutamente non è
vero non è permesso in serie c1 alla
predetta benefico perché conosci le
persone non lavora non avrei mai
azzeccato ride tutta vita a new york in
vacanza a tokyo io metterei new york
city perché so che ci sono già stato
sono e se la serata giocano preferiresti
avere un iphone o un android
no placement android perché iphone nuovo
conosciuto anche io proprio vero allora
preferiresti essere cioè fanno schifo
tutte e due pro preferireste essere
appunto ripetutamente da un calabrone
giapponese che io direi a tokyo ci sono
i calabroni giappone perché c'è il ragno
ora la gente invece tutti hanno limitato
cioè perché pensano di diventare
spiderman pensano in realtà non funziona
così
penso che brutto essere calabrone menti
nato praticamente giocato calabria
mentre il 21 dicembre 2012 che c'è già
stato preferirsi ci fosse un apocalisse
zombie o un'invasione aliena
io lo so che non lo so non ho io lo ho
la guerra dei mondi o devo il kinder
zombie fan troppo favore invasione
aliena
forse perché gli alieni puzza di meno
però alla fine che cambia molto meno
degli zombie sono morti da cittadini non
siano putrefazione non lo so
[Musica]
idea ma dai tutti non hanno detto lee e
nate ford forse aliena perché almeno
scopriamo delle nuove tecnologie poi
moriamo però almeno scopriamo quelle due
aliena hanno messo tutti i top tutti
zombie esce alla playstation
preferiresti non essere in grado di
parlare o non essere in grado di
camminare nel camminare ricavi panna io
per non essere in grado non farlo ma
parte che camminare già cammino niente
ad essere più prendo sempre la macchina
ad andare per far 10 mentre non essere
in grado di parlare tanto il mini dowson
bellio stesso essere appeso a un cappio
può essere decapitato da una
ghigliottina caudio per carpi a vita è
tale non è soffre di meno con la
ghigliottina una ghigliottina in una
frazione di secondo non senti niente
invece li na vince alla lotteria vivere
il doppio del tempo che sta per vivere
il doppio del tempo e gioco tutti i
giorni alla schedina e capace che il
doppio del tempo
no invece tutti i soldi gente che non
merita tempo preferiresti essere
napoleone o giulio cesare questa
comunque la rai ghigliottina
da pochi giorni è beccato pugnali dietro
napoleone noi la pole ha vissuto
sull'isola d'elba un sacco di tempo ha
vissuto allora piccoletto allora o e se
i nano però vivi sull'isola d'elba o
muori però le cose atleta l'hanno
ammazzato è presso le prestano di 55
anni giulio cesare ma che mi sa che
anche napoleone non è più andato molto
più avanti 51 l'aveva hai detto
preferiresti smettere di fare la doccia
o smettere di davart i denti io non
faccio né uno nell'arte tra l'altro non
smetto
lavare i denti aism ha fatto tanto non
vino un pozzo mai
non bisogna poi no poi fattibile sempre
nel bidet e cioè con la stessa acqua
rivivere completamente da solo su
un'isola o a lavorare tanto in una
fabbrica bruttura alla vita l'isola cast
away
la parte ci andrei proprio grande poi ho
giocato ad è fuori stanza quindi
tranquilli ma se che ci andrà la
velocità della luce o leggere la mente
lo cita la luce velocità 1 anche leggere
la mente cita la luce verso i pianeti
sarà questo lo combini a tempo infinito
il motore dove vorresti essere un
sempreverde un grifondoro grifondoro se
in un mappa non ami mi sembra più bello
celate d'oro che non serve serve verde
che i fondi sono già i nomi anche un
percorso per peggiore per l'altro
o forse grifondoro ma per un motivo
perché sono molto cupo di mio
c'è una persona molto dietro secondo
polizia deve avere di vetro voldemort e
quindi non ho vinto di grifondoro
iscritto souleiman ems tu non sai cosa
sono disco prodotto quindi elementi sono
molto buone di skeet sirico skittles
evincono le scritte sono buonissime non
è un placement come fare che non è un
placement fanno cagare lisi preferiresti
prevenire la seconda guerra mondiale
tutte le morti legate alla guerra che ne
seguirono incluso l'olocausto o curare
tutte le forme di cancro e malattie
sessualmente trasmissibili in chiusura
di s la seconda
ma mica tanto guarda che vabbè tanto per
quanto riguarda gli esseri umani che non
possiamo cambiare meglio la seconda come
non ci curiamo tutti hanno messo la
seconda tutti cos'è la tavola periodica
e una tavoletta e ogni tanto no devi
fare e t4 lavori già ogni due settimane
periodicamente la devi fare e la tavola
che apparecchi ogni due settimane
no no vince la medaglia d'oro però poi
creare un nuovo elemento si sa la
medaglia d'oro alle olimpiadi
il serio che tipo quell'elemento che ti
somiglia di più a nome mio e laurenzio
cioè il sergio of surgeons dio johnson
adamello nostro olimpiadi ecco questa è
una domanda giusta preferireste essere
cenerentola o ariel quella caccia più
capelli io direi fate chiari era un
detersivo
no quello è un altro cenerentola è
quella che diventerà la scarpetta reale
quella che vive sotto l'acqua schiume
aria aria l'aria altro tardo ci sta
perché le scarpate ce n'è anche una
sfigata
sì il titanico si amico di hitler allora
la data room preferiresti essere stato
sul titanic può essere stato amico di
hitler amico dietro ma è sul titanic do
muri che noi possiamo parlarne al brunch
è scritto è in entrambi i casi si
sarebbe finito come pensi che sarebbe
finito quindi saresti morto in tutti e
due i casi io il titanic perché io ci
stavo di brutto sulla formula se io ci
stava un po di no no io titanic è
assolutamente sono appropriati che sono
la porta ci stavo di brutto parte che
noi siamo in 5 6 c cos'è citate 50
attenzione invece la prossima volta
allora sul titanic con hitler sulla
porta farà questa catena previsti essere
ucciso in un film di sean o in un film
di final destination
però i due figlie dovevano morto
ovviamente faina l'unione nel sonno
penso quello di destination si fanno a
destinare capita solo è bruttissimo
ragazzi di recupido può concludersi qua
è stato molto carino e in alt ambito
molto tranquillo e volevo farla un botto
perché cioè mi piace nostre cose se mi
piace un sacco vanno coi miei amici
vabbè c'è un po di problemi quindi
ragazzi spero di video vi sia piaciuto
grazie papà per aver partecipato questo
video qua è stato molto carino e mi
piace anche al comitato descrizione sono
state vi ci vediamo
[Musica]